I got you on my mind
oh that's easy sweet yeah it would make
up four times I haven't slept
actually I need a lot more than five
days to make up for I need a year of
sleeping yeah I heard you but I still
don't get it
I think the pigeon steps is pretty cool
but I don't know I think I'm a bit of a
dodgy looking runner I only noticed when
I watch footage battle myself running
but but I don't know it's something it's
like when I look in the mirror and think
I look pretty good and then I get a
selfie and I look terrible I think it's
the same with running I think I look
fine and then I watch it back and I look
like baby understand why I got you hot
I would I would much rather be hot and
cold I hate the cold and I genuinely
like start getting like blue fingers and
toes and lips if I'm Mike and I feel the
cold more than the average person and
why
I'll go for chapped lips because I like
to pick things so I was picking them all
although gross so I wear one or he wears
one I'd love to see my boyfriend in red
leotard he probably put it off yeah I
wait to say BAE's oh yeah all right
baked beans without doubt just cuz it's
baked means my favorite I can eat them
everyday baked beans and cheese why I
gotcha